this is a production of Cornell
University but what I want to tell you a
little bit about is how we're starting
to use some of the concepts of evolution
and machine learning and combining those
together to really figure out and drive
functional variant discovery and what we
hope will eventually become breeding 4.0
I want to first highlight that the work
I'll be telling you about today who's
been supported by usda-ars in the
National Science Foundation
but the real thought and efforts behind
all of this type of work is coming from
an incredible group of collaborators
I've had the pleasure of collaborating
with over the years sir Miller was
helping me count up all of our
collaborators over the years and we've
actually collaborated with like 1,200
people now over the last 20 years and
that working across that global
community it's been such a pleasure to
learn from everybody and to make
progress in this and this is some of our
current collaborators right now that
have helped shape our thinking I want to
give you all a little feel for where
we're driving to and that comes out of
our labs mission and so our labs mission
the very first one element is a very
straightforward one what's the genetic
basis of natural diversity simple to say
hard to figure out but essentially how
does it change in DNA get converted into
a change out in the field something we
can see and work with with models of
those we can then apply that knowledge
to help breed crops for the US and for
the world and so I won't be talking a
lot about what we're doing there but we
try to use our understanding and the top
part to help people across the world
build an engineering and IT systems to
help breed crops the world and then
finally we do all this in the context of
what should we discover in what crops
should we breed in order to reduce the
environmental impact of agriculture so
I've also in the last couple months been
given a number of talks down in
Washington DC and so frequently I'm
asked what is breeding okay and that
actually is a harder question that I
thought initially because you know we
all around here think we
breeding is but this is the definition I
came up with and essentially we view
this as the design and selection of
organisms for human purposes and so if
you start asking you know what could we
apply breeding to and if you go through
the UN sustainable development goals
they lay out 17 goals that are critical
across the globe for the next 20 years
and where could breeding contribute to
each one of these and it turns out that
breeding can contribute I'm not saying
it's the dominant element or anything it
can play a role in 10 out of the 17
sustainable development goals so the
reason that I'm interested in taking
quantitative genetics and applied it to
breeding is because the leverage of what
we can do and impact the globe is so
great and so I think if each of us is
can play a little role in figuring out
how we can solve some of these 17 issues
we can have a real impact across the
globe
[Music]
maybe it's 11 of them I think excellent
question so in terms of the evolution of
plant breeding though where if we come
from as its mentioned I have this
background in archaeology so I always
think about what reading is and
quantitative genetics from this very
long time depth and so 10,000 years ago
we I would say we started out was called
breeding 1.0 which are using phenotypic
selection to decide what species should
be domesticated
there's a quarter-million species plant
species out there about 5000 of them
have been domesticated to some degree
and people were really testing out
species level diversity in applying
selection to some of those species to
really drive them into new and different
Corrections starting a little over 100
years ago
I think the key element was we started
having controlled trials where we
controlled the genetics out of that came
or understanding of quantitative
genetics experimental design but really
the key elements and allowing us to make
progress and those statistics arises out
of our knowledge of plant breeding
our desire to do plant breeding and of
course equipment and tools like
harvesters really help drive our ability
to provide and produce selection
effectively then a little over of almost
20 years ago now genomic selection
arises where we're essentially using
anonymous markers across the genome to
really drive selection and produce crops
faster and better now for most
sophisticated breeding programs across
the globe and major companies genomic
selection is now the norm it's being
applied in all of our major crops in
each of those companies but I think one
of the challenges we have across the
nation and across the globe is to make
sure genomic selection breeding 3.0 gets
applied to those 5,000 other species
that have been domesticated or to all
the environments and all the breeding
efforts across the rest of the globe so
although I'll be talking most about
bringing 4.0 today we also do spend a
lot of time and I think our whole
community should spend a lot of time
making sure that breeding 3.0 gets
applied everywhere
so finally breeding 4.0 is really about
designing genomes and in order to do
this you have to identify the causative
nucleotides that are underlined
quantitative and complex trait variation
and then we could imagine using an
editing technology and our understanding
of physiology and molecular biology it's
really drive things forward and I'll
talk about how we're doing some efforts
to help us identify those positive
nucleotides so when I think about where
variation comes from I think the first
place we can think about it is you know
every generation 90 new mutations occur
and in the case of maize and some of
those are adaptive some of those are
deleterious and the most of them were
neutral and fundamentally the question
that our group is trying to ask is of
those 90 mutations that arise every
generation and they maybe are of course
are passed on generation after
generation for thousands even millions
of years which follow into each of these
different categories and that's what
we're trying to ask and trying to get
and figure that out as easily and fast
as we possibly can and why I care about
speed and cost is for
there's a lot of genetic variation out
there indicate a small sample of maze
lines they capture about 80 million
different genetic variants across the
genome and we think there's on the order
of a few hundred thousand functional
variants that are really contributing to
most of the phenotypic variation out
there the question is how do we go from
the top of that funnel to the bottom of
that funnel as cheaply and inexpensively
as possible and so it really is a cost
question of efficiency to move from the
top to the bottom so we've worked on a
lot of different methodologies across
here and I'll talk about a couple of
them today with special emphasis on
using conservation expression and
machine learning to get from the top to
the bottom and I want to start out with
highlighting that evolution has turned
out to probably be the most powerful
tool we have for figuring out what our
functional variants across the genome
and of course this shouldn't come to
surprise to anybody
Jib Jansky 50 or 60 years ago reminded
us of this that nothing in biology makes
sense except in the light of evolution
but just to give you a kind of a
quantitative example how powerful
evolution is at identifying things let's
think about field trials so a decade or
so ago we did then create the maze name
population it had 5000 inbred lines and
through a lot of work we created them we
groom outed for example one experiment
eight location lots of clones at each
one and effectively we were able to map
a five kernel per plant difference down
to the level of an individual gene okay
so that in may regard seems like that's
a pretty good mapping accuracy and
everything but how is that compared to
evolution and so well so the key thing
to realize about evolution is it's
really the integration of billions of
years of field trials you know every
individual is competing
it's either surviving or not or dying to
the passions gametes on and so in the
diverse species for example maize if we
sample a thousand different maize lines
for capturing about three million years
of evolutionary time by a Sam having a
sample
of a thousand lines those thousand
extant lines are the product of
populations that had an effective
population size of nearly a hundred
thousand individuals and the key thing
is selection can see a difference of one
kernel out out of 250 plants so in
comparison to what we were able to do in
a very large field experiment it's about
1,200 times more sensitive than than
what we can do in a large build
experiment because it effectively we
have the time and evolution to integrate
across all those different events now
what's the problem with using evolution
the big issue is we don't really know
what the conditions were under which
selection operated so that's the great
weakness of using evolution but we've
also gotten in the last couple decades
getting pretty good at identifying what
regions of the genome have been the
product of domestication or the targets
of domestication and in those regions we
actually know those are are the regions
where the rules of selection have
changed all right when we talk about a
domestication locus what that really is
is a location in the genome where
selection is going in a different
direction
today and under human selection and it
was under natural selection and so in
the case of maze which is probably our
most highly domesticated crop out there
there's about a thousand domestication
or improvement Llosa across the genome
which is about 4% of all the genes out
there so from one point of view you know
we can't be sure what's going on there
what the we can't use evolution as a
guide necessarily to pick out what is
the correct direction to take those loci
but what this does suggest is that the
other 96% of the genome essentially the
rules that have played for the last few
million years are probably the same
rules and important directions that are
important today photosynthesis in may
still operates pretty much by the same
rules as it did a million years ago five
million years ago and so on so if we use
that knowledge to try to figure out
deleterious variants
we've used essentially evolutionary
conservation to work down this trail and
so let me explain how we do that well
the first thing about in order used
conservation we were using it to trying
to tackle a question about what's the
what produces deleterious mutations and
then what produces heterosis and why we
care about deleterious mutations is if
over 100 years ago geneticists figured
out that essentially deleterious
mutations are likely the product or what
produced had a roast is a hybrid vigor
and essentially we complement them and
we get it out hybrid vigor out of the
system and of course amazed home a seed
industry has grown out of this and so I
think the question of what is the basis
of heterosis it's pretty much a solved
question for the last hundred years the
question that has not been solved is
what are the individual nucleotides
across the genome that contribute to
heterosis so the basic process we've
understood for a century but what are
those individual deleterious mutations
and so a former postdoc in the group
yeah Eli Rogers Melnick tackled this by
asking the question let me take the
maize genome and line it up across a
wide range of other species and identify
what regions of the genome are conserved
across this wide range of species and he
lined up maize for everything all the
way out to arouser topsis and grapes and
so on and what he found is about 10% of
the genome was Allina belen constrained
I'd highlight the most of what he's
talking about are the genes these are
the energetic regulatory regions do not
align across this range of diversity
it's pretty much just genes that align
at this scale so but he was able
base-pair by base-pair able to ask the
question how conserve is every base out
there and then if you see a genetic
polymorphism at a base that's incredibly
conserved across this entire phylogeny
the odds that are deleterious or
substantially increased so the same type
of process is also now being used by
people in human genetics to identify a
disease low sigh and so on and so I
applied that to our question here in
maize and we have a very strong prior of
what we think should happen we
there's mutations we know that the key
way to get rid of deleterious mutations
is through recombination that breaks
things up and then essentially selection
can eliminate them and so we expect to
see a pattern such that in low
recombination regions of the genome we
have a buildup of deleterious mutations
and in high recombination regions of the
genome we have fewer and that's exactly
what we saw is that in low recombination
we had a buildup of deleterious
mutations and in high recombination we
had fewer oh I do want to highlight
though there are still lots of
deleterious mutations in high
recombination regions of the genome the
genome the zig feel about ninety
mutations are occurring every generation
and they're all across the genome pretty
much evenly across that genome and so
and the genes are in the high
recombination region so yes there's a
buildup the population genetic
prediction that we are able to purge
selfish mutations better and high
recombination is true but there are
still deleterious mutations everywhere
just because the pressure of mutation is
so strong and so you know I then lined
up a lot of those deleterious mutations
with a couple different aspects of the
genome and the first one he wanted to
test was how did this line up where with
where people had previously mapped
heterosis in maize and in the early
1990s Charlie Stuber had identified that
the center or para centromeric region of
chromosome 5 exhibited the highest level
of heterosis in maize and so Eli took
his model del judge mutations took them
at from across chromosome five and
that's exactly what he saw a buildup of
deleterious mutations right in the pair
of centromeric region of the genome and
far less buildup across the rest of it
the green is the recombination rate and
as you'll see in maize we have a very
low recombination rate all across that
pair of centromeric region and so it's
very difficult for the genome to purge
these deleterious mutations in those
regions but so the pattern in our
agreement with heterosis for this
analysis made a lot of sense so this but
as I mentioned the way we were doing
their conservation analysis we really
could only look at essentially genes and
conserved pretty much protein
conserve proteins there and so the
second question we would ask is whether
or not we were seeing the same type of
patterns looking at RNA and expression
patterns some other analysis we had done
that suggested about half of phenotypic
variation is the product of expression
differences half of it's from coding
differences and so is the genome able to
purge deleterious mutations better in
these expression domain or does it do
worse at that and so this is where Carl
crumbling a former graduate student
worked on this question in the real
element and key from doing this analysis
is we need to collect enough expression
data to from enough different lines that
we could determine what was a rare and
aberrant expression pattern and so what
he did is he got robot roboticized
3 prime RNA seek profiling up and
running guide down for about 25 bucks of
sample and he was then able to profile
nearly 2,000 samples for their RNA
levels and with that large data set we
then essentially had expression measures
on tens of millions of different genes
and alleles all across this panel that
effectively allowed us start asking
questions about what are rare expression
patterns and the hypothesis he wanted to
test was one that Greg Gibson had laid
out and for Human Genetics and
essentially the hypothesis is following
and the test is is following so we kind
of expect low expression if you've been
expression patterns out for each gene if
rare alleles and deleterious alleles are
playing an important role what we expect
to see is that essentially low
expression will be the product of lots
of rare alleles and high expression will
also be the product of lots of rare
alleles
well intermediate expression well you
know won't have an enrichment of rare
alleles and so this is the basic pattern
you would expect if you think that rare
alleles and deleterious alleles are
driving extremes in expression and so
what's the alternative hypothesis to
this well the alternative is that common
alleles actually get stacked up in a way
so it's
the extremes are being are the product
of lots of different common alleles and
so is that like they'd be common well
across the whole genome when we see
extremes in phenotype like flowering
time it's a is the product of dozens of
genes with essentially if relatively
common alleles gain stacked up in order
to produce those extremes of extreme
early flowering is the product of lots
of common alleles being stacked up the
extreme late flowering is deprived again
of lots of common alleles being stacked
up so a genome-wide scale that's the
pattern we actually do see common
alleles in general or what are
contributing to a lot of our extremes
and phenotypes but at the level of an
individual gene recombination is of
course very limited there's a limited
amount of recombination in each from a
regulatory region and so this is a type
of area for extremes maybe the product
actually of a buildup of deleterious
mutations and so in Greg Gibson's model
what we would expect to see is
essentially a u-shape plot here if you
were to apply out the average number of
rare alleles on the Y and then on the X
we go from low expression to high
expression we expect to see a u like
this if rare alleles are driving things
and that's exactly what Karl saw so when
he profile using these different maze
lines essentially low expression where
we see low expression we see this more
than doubling and the number of rare
alleles and we do also see an increase
in high expression as the product of an
increased number of rare alleles so both
extremes seem to be pushed by rare
alleles asymmetry between these two
suggests that rare and deleterious
alleles it's easier to knockdown
expression than it is to increase
expression so both directions we see
that extreme on both sides and so where
you really want to be is somewhere here
in the middle that's the sweet spot
where expression is it's somewhere in
the middle you don't want to be at
either of those two extremes and that
basic hypothesis about extremes and the
wind essentially the optimal organism is
an organism that essentially has balance
expression everywhere is effectively the
dosage hypothesis
Jim Burt's allure has been advocating
this for a number of years as the basis
of mace heterosis and it works well with
a model you're with deleterious mutation
since and so on but essentially let me
explain the model essentially and if you
have balanced expression into all your
genes your protein complexes your
metabolism everything else is kind of
that goes as expected that produces a
healthy plant if you have extremes in
expression your protein complexes don't
form correctly metabolites you get
buildup of the wrong metabolites to the
wrong time points you essentially are
wasting energy all over the place if you
are not in the center everywhere and
that produces weak and inefficient
organisms and so in order to be optimal
you should be average everywhere that's
kind of is the key element there and so
that's what the basic model in heterosis
works just fine with this type of model
that essentially be averaged everywhere
and you will be highly vigorous and so
what Carl did is he came up with a very
simple statistic of just cumulative
dysregulation across every gene in the
genome he didn't give any genes greater
weight or a different way from what we
know that's very naive but essentially
communitive dysregulation does correlate
with see weight or yield he also used an
approach where he created a statistic
based on the deviations in expression in
order to try to predict the amount of
variance explained in seed weight and
here he was able to find anywhere from
20 to 30 percent of seed whey is being
explained by this dysregulation these
patterns of dysregulation so we think
think that maybe about half of
phenotypic variation is coming out of
processes that involve these dosage
aspects of essentially not having
balanced dosage at each gene the genome
is perdu producing a lot of the
phenotypic variation that is out there
okay now I told you about those two
different approaches that we were using
from the top to the bottom but if we
really want to get down to individual
nucleotides so that we know we can start
talking about editing and so on how do
we get there part of the problem with
all these deleterious mutations is that
they're rare it's very difficult to map
rare things okay and we don't want to
spend a whole bunch of time taking every
rare allele that's out there and III
Singh it's a little frequency and order
in order to map it and so this is where
machine learning comes in where we're
effectively learning the rules of how
the genome works so we can spot these
rare and deleterious mutations all
across the genome and we've been are
starting to think and apply this all
across essentially the central dogma and
beyond but what I'll be talking to you
about today is how we're using machine
learning to model both chromatin
structure and expression patterns in
maize and actually amazing sorghum and
so you know why are we talking about
machine learning well you know obviously
it's a it's a hot topic you're hearing
about it all the time you know you can
be photographing or machine learning
models will identify you incredibly
quickly you walk underneath the camera
it knows exactly who you are and the
fact that that can be done and could be
done for us you know why can't shouldn't
we apply these incredible tools to
understanding molecular biology too and
the key reason machine learning does
work though is it allows us to process
massive amounts of data it allows us
really to generalize rules from one
portion of the genome to the rest it
allows us to generalize rules from a
reference genotype so all the other
genotypes and finally if the model is
robust enough if we can be used to
really determine if it given genetic
variant matters and I think some of the
pushback on machine learning has been
historically that people especially in
the basic science world is that it's a
black box model okay and absolutely you
can treat machine learning entirely in a
black as a black box model and not
understand the underlying biology that
goes under is underlying it
as I'll show you we've been doing a lot
more work to essentially once you create
the model try to probe the model and ask
the question what's going on what did it
learn and now can they teach us
something about what was going on there
so I'm going to tell you about a series
of models and these were developed by
three great postdocs in the group
Katherine Mejia hi Wong and Jacob
Washburn and the models are fairly
straightforward to explain what we
wanted to do was take sequence and in
just sequence so no other annotation on
the sequence we don't want to know what
methylation SAS is we don't want to know
what the chrome any of the chromatin
structure I just want to take sequence
and from that be able to predict the
following is the chromatin open what
transcription factor binds there is it a
pseudo gene and what is the expression
level of The Associated gene next to
that sequence and the second class of
models is if I have two homologous
sequences and I differ differentiate the
expression of allele a versus a lil B
and figure out which one has the greater
level of expression so those are the
five models we've been exploring last
year and essentially we're using a
couple different approaches the first is
coming from natural language processing
very similar to when you type something
into Google and it's trying to process
your language and figure out what you're
after and what we've done here
Catherines work on these Kaymer language
based approaches you're breaking a
sequence into k-mers and then as I'll
show you your tree is essentially a bag
of words that we're modeling and then
the second class of models are these
convolutional neural Nets historically
they've been used to essentially do
image processing and we're essentially
converting sequences and ordered images
and then we're using the CNN's processed
them at different scales and then using
neural nets to integrate these processed
sequences so a little bit more detail on
what the camer bag of word type models
are so let's take DNA and effectively
it's a bet could be treated as a bag of
words very short sequences or the came
we take those we count them up and then
we can essentially fit them in a
regression model to make a prediction
and a bag of words model is no more
complicated than that the vector based
ones which rely on the ordering of the
words is more complicated and some more
powerful but essentially the bag of
words one is as simple it's just
counting up Kaymer's and fitting it to a
regression model okay when we need to
talk about the convolutional neural nets
we're essentially taking a sequence and
each base pair is getting Rhian coded
and so what you're seeing is essentially
we're making a black and white picture
where A's are encoded here Caesar
encoded there and then from that we take
convolutions and what convolutions are
doing is that they're looking across
that image and trying to highlight
various features at certain scales that
then can be passed on to the neural nets
and so those convolutions that you probe
the regions summarize that information
there and then once we have those
convolutions with neural nets we can
relate those convolutions to any trait
or attribute in our case we want to
relate that sequence to expression
levels and so a little bit more about
how we measure whether or not we've been
able to create machine learning mouths
or have any good already and use we use
whatever known as the ROC curves or
receiver operating characteristic curves
and essentially these are just ways to
count how well you're doing and
measuring comparing your truths and
false positive rates and essentially the
way we've set them up for the this talk
here our random expectation is along the
diagonal and we expect that to
essentially produce an area under the
curve or a ROC curve of about 0.5 if we
have a perfect classifier the table it
of completely differentiate to two
separate classes with no errors we it'll
follow along there and essentially its
area under the curve would be 100% and
so this is one way we measure whether or
not we've been able to create a machine
learning model that is of value and so
Katherine took this type of model
was using the chip seek data from the
transcription factor fee of for to train
on and she was able to using that bag of
words model be able to create a model
that had very high levels of accuracy at
0.99 and ascend she was almost perfectly
classified where each of those
transcription factors were binding all
across the genome and it wasn't just
that transcription factor she's used the
chip seek data from not at one also very
high levels of accuracy we had emanation
open chromatin data that she was able to
use and again it was able to Train very
good models there and then she also was
able to classify core promoter sequences
with high levels of accuracy so
essentially we and she's been able to
now repeat this for about a hundred
other transcription factors with other
collaborators and effectively we can now
create machine learning models that
model where transcription factors going
to bind with high levels of accuracy and
essentially start annotating all sorts
of other genomes with it especially
within maize but one of the questions we
did want to ask is how good are these
models transferable from maize to say
other species and so Katherine asked
that question
she took her core promoter model and so
it was great in maize but then she took
it to sorghum yeah it was okay it's not
you know the transferability from mesa
sorghum wasn't as great as we would have
hoped there now we know strategies about
how we could make a model that work
across both of them the key element is
we would probably train across both
maize and sorghum simultaneously rather
than just training on one species at a
time but some of the models for example
her not at one model for maize it
actually had superb transfer ability all
the way to rice so that when transferred
65 million years without a problem so
each of these models some have high
levels of transfer ability some don't
but there are strategies for figuring
out and improving the transfer ability
across species these camera models are
also really we talked about the black
box aspect all of that was pretty much
black box you can open up the models
okay how did the model figure out that
this is a core promotor and so of course
we know the Tata box should play an
important role in defining a core
promoter sequence and so what she's
plotted out here is essentially the
weight of each Kaymer and there's
thousands of Kaymer she was looking at
but these are the Tata light cameras and
the most important ones for defining a
core promoter are listed here as you see
they line up right next to where the
transcriptional start site is so
essentially this black box model the way
it learned how transcription starts and
in maize was finding the tata box and
[Music]
learning essentially the rules that of
course obviously everybody's known this
for years but it was able to learn
effectively the right rules on how this
worked ok we've also though found that
training models can be tricky and
machine learning models they're
incredibly proud they can learn and
memorize virtually anything the question
is whether or not it's letting what you
wanted to learn and this is where the
last six months or so we've been really
doing a lot more work to make sure we're
training on the attributes of the models
that we really care about and turned out
that a lot of our models especially when
we went across lots of different genes
our models were effectively able to
memorize the evolutionary history of how
every genes relate to every other team
okay which isn't you know that's an
interesting evolutionary story but
doesn't teach you the rules of how
malleco biology works and exactly how a
promoter works we didn't want to just
memorize evolution so what we've done is
we've started to think through how can
we use evolution as our aid not
something we just memorize and so we've
set up two different ways of setting up
our training versus our testing the
first one I want a group set up was
essentially gene family guided training
where you train on one set of gene
families so you take half the gene
families across mate and you train on
them but you hide all the other gene
families but you test if your model is
doing very well with a group of gene
families the model has never seen before
if you are learning things
that are transferable to gene families
you've never seen before then it's
likely a good model it just hasn't just
memorized recent evolution in order to
figure things out and the second way to
do it is to essentially take a couple
related species to one another and
essentially compare the orthologs
against one another in order to do the
cassette of the contrast there and
that's what we call the ortholog
contrast training model I'll go into
that and Jacob Washburn has been leading
the effort in those types of analyses so
in that first one
hi everyone to ask the question can he
train a model to identify what are the
pseudo genes across the genome and which
are the genes that are highly expressed
and so normally he's taking the promoter
sequence the utrs about 50 and her base
pairs up there 1,500 base pairs on the
3-prime utr and beyond beyond the
terminator throwing that into a model
letting the convolutional neural net
then predict expression levels and what
he did is he took a data set where we
had expression across 66 different
tissues and took the maximal expression
level and he asked the question kenny
differentiate between the genes that are
never expressed versus the genes that
are expressed that's the combination of
these two or just the really highly
expressed genes and i preempt this next
slide we're a lot better at
differentiating between this group
versus that group and differentiating
between here and all of these but the
model is still quite good and
essentially when you try to
differentiate between off versus high he
has about an 80% accuracy there and if
you just use either the promoter or the
terminator sequence and if you combine
the two together we get a substantial
boost
so essentially signal for whether or not
the gene is on or a high is coming from
both the 5 Prime and 3 prime end of the
gene and we can create a pretty good
model classify each of those the the
second question that we were interested
in is which allele is more highly
expressed here we're taking two
homologous sequences and from a person
quantitative genetics background this is
really kind of the fundamental question
I have of molecular biology I want to
know a given variant does it change does
it make something go up does it make it
go down or does it have no effect those
are the once I have to get down to the
right side of those then I can throw it
into a more complex model of
quantitative genetics and parameterize
everything so this is the salah' model I
really want to use in order to
parameterize the entire genome and the
way Jacob has gone about this is
essentially reframing it using these
orthologs and I mentioned we're
essentially comparing the orthologs in
two different portions or two different
species training on them and then
testing on a different set there so
instead of just having one sequence and
fruit making a prediction of phenotype
we're taking two sequences and comparing
them and what we found is that rather
than actually predicting exactly the
difference in expression we're most
interested in really predicting whether
or not it went up or went down and I'll
also highlight that we found out that
there's a lot of genes especially when
we have to compare between species that
very subtle differences in the
expression we're not very good at
predicting whether or not a gene went up
or down slightly between major sorghum
but if we take a look at the top twenty
or twenty percent of the genes that
really moved up and down in an
expression between maize and sorghum or
logs then we have a very good prediction
accuracy okay and some of this is maybe
our ability to be able to really tell
whether or not something went up or down
isn't great if the expression
differences are really slight so Jacob
took this model very similar to what
high exactly the same way that I broke
up the sequences here but he's
essentially taking two genes in the
model and then letting the convolutional
neural ad pick out which hot ortholog is
more highly expressed and so the pattern
here was was somewhat different so the
first thing to highlight is that the
promoter five prime end versus three
prime end it was really the three prime
end that was giving us much more
information than the promoter was and we
didn't get much improvement by combining
the two of them together
and as I mentioned we if we only look at
the 20% of the genes and really a big
expression differences then we have a
really accurate model there's real
subtle differences between maize and
sorghum we're not able to pick those out
particularly well but if there's a big
difference we can create a classifier
that's actually really accurate but the
interesting thing is most of the signal
was coming from the Terminator and of
the sequences and to plot that out again
we can once we've created these models
we can go through base pair by base pair
and ask what did the model learn what
base pairs were most important for
making that prediction and so that's
what you're seeing here is essentially
these are called saliency Maps and what
they're doing is they're telling us what
base pair by base pair is providing the
most information and high expression and
it turned out when we do that ortholog
contrast model the the sequence is right
before the Terminator sequence were the
most important for determining the
expression levels Wow if we look at
pseudogenes five prime utrs were most
important and so on so we are learning
that you know for each of these
different models to proportion to the
gene seem to be most important for
explaining this so what this is
suggesting is the model that I was
working on was really asking questions
about how different classes of genes
control their regulation that seems to
be an issue that's substantially
regulated by the five prime UTR the
promoter sequence and so on how to
define tuning of how one gene changes
its expression through evolutionary time
seems to be coming more from the three
prime UTR side so whether the gene is on
or off by prime whether that exact
amount of expression that's left on and
the fine-tuning of it and what makes the
difference between maize and sorghum may
well be coming from the three prime UTR
side of things so at least that's our
current hypothesis so I want to end up
here though is can we also probe these
models and get down to that level we're
really starting to ask the question can
we edit and Kathryn took one of her
models she lined up her day
and her models nodded one against
empirical data the sir Hakes group
produced a decade ago and where they
tweaked individual base pairs and then
did a competition assay to ask do these
individual base pairs matter and what
you'll see is that where she predicts
high regulatory probabilities that's
what we see and where she predicts lo
and these individual base pair changes
they line up with the competition assays
so I think we've gotten to a level where
these machine learning models can be
trained that they have the sensitivity
to ask a question if one or two bases
are changed here that that's likely to
produce an effect so what are the limits
of our current models so if there's
deleterious models I was telling you
about they're good at splitting neutral
from functional and what do I mean by
that let's say there's 80 million
variants out there I think we're at a
stage we're at least four amino acids I
can tell you these are the 2,000 or
3,000 bad amino acids out there so from
one point of view we separated 3,000
away from 80 million that seems really
good we're not very good at telling you
among those last 3,000 which is the
worst one okay we're not very good at
ranking within those last three thousand
we're also when we go across this much
diversity we're missing the regulatory
landscape how maze is controlling this
expression versus rabbitov sis things
have changed so dramatically that the
rule we can't learn all the rules from
rabbitov sis how each individual gene is
being expressed and made and of course
we have very diverse physiology so how
are we working to get around that well
initially we only had four species of
Andrew pagana and so what we're doing
now is we've just got started in our
project that's been funded by the
National Science Foundation with my
colleagues toby kellogg matt Huffer jeff
ross abara
adam steeple and cheese son and we're
gonna focus on one clade and so why do
we care about focusing on a clade well I
mentioned initially that Mays we've
learned a lot from Ace but we with a
thousand genomes for the sequencing we
only capture about three million years
of evolution if we were to apply that
same thousand GM's worth of information
across this entire plate from say 900
different Andrew pagana we would capture
1.5 billion years of evolutionary time
okay so we've dramatically increased the
total amount of time by 300 fold that
we're now sampling I was telling you how
sensitive evolution is at detecting
Fitness differences but now we've
turbocharged it now we have 300 times
more information and the key thing is
within this clade they all share nad PC
for photosynthesis they're all the same
roughly and the big scheme of things the
same physiology and similar
developmental patterns so we're not
trying to make models that work all the
way out to arrive at ops we're working
with a group of grasses that untrain
system says many of them all look very
similar to one another okay but they've
adapted all over the planet so one way
to view this is this is really
saturation evolutionary analysis every
ancestral base pair here has actually
been mutated 50 times somewhere coming
out here into those 900 different
species so every base pair has been
whacked by evolution and mutations all
over the place and so we can actually
start measuring and constraint directly
these species although they
developmentally look very similar i've
actually adapted to an incredible range
of also environmental adaptations from
ross to very hot temperatures throughout
the environments to essentially in
swamps and so from across this entire
species we can learn how these species
have adapted to some Ahlers diverse
environmental adaptations and so we're
working to essentially sample sequence
analyze all 900 of those species genomes
in the next several years and we really
see that evolution and machine learning
we will be bringing those together where
we see that evolution provides us this
nearly infinite level of mutagenesis it
provides us an ability to see Fitness
effects that are a thousandfold more
powerful than field experiments and it
provides this incredible range of
environmental histories well machine
learning is allowing us to scale to
genome sizes learning can
generalized and we can throw virtually
anything into a machine learning model
so heterogeneous inputs can go in and we
can still make sense of it so these are
the may the tools we have handed here
here and this is where we're working a
lot now is to figure out what are the
most intelligent ways to combine all
these together so we can identify
prioritize those individual snips so
that we can go from a place where we
have models of how each of the various
steps and that central dog will work all
the way out to physiology we can then
test those hypotheses based on how they
work in standing variation if they work
well we go ahead and we start editing
and selecting away so I want to end here
that a lot of folks my group have
contributed to these ideas I highlighted
many of the people the postdocs and
students who produce a lot of exact data
sets I was talking about but my group
and all those great collaborations and
Babli we've been probably really three
people in the group really helped bring
everything together and that Center for
May Peter Bradbury and Sarah Miller and
I'd be happy to take some questions
[Applause]
seems like a moving car right so I mean
yeah so the question is how do you
change four different developmental time
points and everything so it's you've a
venturi right now everything is at the
same developmental stage okay and so the
models we've created are at it for a
developmental state okay or stage and so
amazing sorghum we can still grow those
two plants side-by-side one another we
can collect expression data side-by-side
for one another and make sense of them
one of the good things though about
expression the data sets are so rich you
can stage one another against yeah
there's so many orthologs so it is
possible to stage models against one
another and just from the empirical data
you can frequently figure out where you
are in development where you are in
various stages so I think
long term though the models absolutely
need to be generalized through the
dynamic you know time changes and that's
not something we've were interested in
we have not I'm sure there will be
situations where the models will not
work as well for certain developmental
aspects but you know I think a lot of
them you know a lot of the development
is you know it's it is timing here
they're stretched out or extended a
little bit more and that produces the
phenotypic effect that you were seeing
but some of the basic patterns and
regulation are pretty similar I mean the
fact that a lot of our maize and sorghum
models the fact that we can even train a
model and expression that's between
maize and photographs really well says
the rules are pretty much the same we're
beneficial alleles much much more
valuable than a gene that everyone
already has right okay yeah so I think
you know the the question is about rare
rare advantageous or adaptive alleles
well so first off there's a certain
level we're never going to capture every
adaptive mutation that's out there but
most adaptive mutations are if they're
really truly our adapter for that
population they will be common there
well but like if you have like a manic
stress like a new one you know a gene
which functions like formerly worked
really great against this nematode
change oh yeah and I agree it's
situations where you have very rapidly
changing you know a Red Queen situation
like biotic stress I think the different
approaches really need to be used figure
out what are the useful alleles they're
Red Queen
I would say is not yeah is this is not
the approach to go find those alleles
I think there are other approaches that
would be far more advantageous for
figuring out disease less items than
this but I would say most of the abiotic
stresses they are yes they may fluctuate
from year to year but over deep time all
the organisms have seen drought they've
seen flooding and things like that so a
lot of those alleles are maintained at
reasonable frequencies and over a
wide-enough panel you'll be able to find
that that allele is adaptive it's common
somewhere and it isn't truly R it may be
rare in your little panel but if it
really is adaptive and you are sampling
as much diversity to say the entire
range of pagani it'll become in a number
of places yeah binding sites so since
the AUC is so high nine nine eight that
must be some features of that or the
connection between the binding sites
sure friends or common features that's
it I don't know if Kathryn is here the
ones that I know were Kathryn here no
okay
the ones that were not very high anybody
else in lab wants to correct me feel
free the ones that were not high
generally the chip seek experiments were
pretty bad okay so the biggest thing
we've seen for the improvement of the
quality of the models is replication of
numerous chip seek experiments and when
they are replicated and you line up the
experiment over and over again those
sites can be modeled really well so the
neat thing also Kathryn has done is
she's been able to take those models and
compare you know for these hundreds
transcription factors compare how what
the model looks like against each one
for each transcription factor and the
families of transcription factors fall
out of it
so suggesting that essentially it really
is learning the basic processes by which
these TX are binding yep yes thank you
so much I'm just looking at
do you think there's a change across the
time future mutations and other factors
so does it mean the product that we have
today even their existence for diseases
for us the same we'll also have a change
for tomorrow a that the was--or it's a
beta and then is that way of stopping or
minimizing this changes across time and
then looking for this so I think the
question of whether or not you know we
reduced her own mutation rate higher
eukaryotes have you know there is
actually probably a fairly strong
selection to keep down that mutation
rate as low as it possibly can and it's
probably about of what at least this
type of flim erase biology can pull off
so I don't know that knocking that I
mean selection has tried to do that
really hard to make incredibly high
fidelity glimmer aces and so I'm not
convinced that that's an easy target to
do is to reduce the total mutation rate
we can screen DNA sequencing that was so
cheap you can essentially screen through
things and just throw out novel me to
any novel mutation though it looks kind
of bad so if you're working in a large
breeding company that you know that is
not a crazy idea that that's how you
things out okay so it was the over the
yeah evolution is I think this kind of
goes back to that the same type of
question that evolution is not always a
great guide for picking out these
abiotic red queen type disease issues
okay that doesn't mean machine learning
couldn't be incredibly powerful for
predicting what ligands are gonna come
together and what you're gonna do that
so I think there's all sorts of black
box types of things or you could have
machine learning you know predicting you
know how to deal with disease resistance
but it's not using exactly the same
evolution that you may use evolutionary
time they're generate the diversity but
it becomes a different question
like essentially the region well that's
why Pioneer hired Eli Rodgers Melnick so
whether or not we could fix heterosis in
the so I mean I think the first question
is whether or not we'll be allowed to
edit okay so there are those issues and
I think that's you know how yeah that
how society will allow that but then
there are going to be I mean you'll
always be able to make a hybrid that is
better and whatever in Bret you've just
made so just because of distributions so
and there are a few low side across the
genome I have no doubt that are truly
over dominant rather than being the
product of dosage pattern or dominance
type point so I think hybrids will
always be better whether or not though
it looks right now amazed hybrid has two
times the yield of its inbreds or three
times those yields of its inbred whether
or not they're I don't you know I think
we can get there I don't know how
quickly will get their genome
rearranging so you don't actually have
genes in all the more accessible
combination no no and I think this is
where maybe didn't emphasize this enough
that a the pair centromeric increase we
see it and it's absolutely the there of
these delatour's mutations but there are
deleterious mutations everywhere okay
and they are enriched in the pair
centromeric regions but most the genes
are still out at the arms and they are
still having lots of deleterious
mutations another thing that Eli figured
out was there's a process bias gene
conversion is actually maintaining
deleterious mutations at high
recombination regions of the genome at
fairly moderate frequencies so there are
other processes that are out there that
are deleterious mutations are everywhere
there just happen to be enriched in a
pair of centromere agreed and so you
would still I mean we see heterosis it's
enriched in the that chromosome five but
we see the evidence of how two roses
everywhere so it's not yeah one so my
question do you think that hybrids would
be a natural situation then you wouldn't
see expect Richmond I mean I mean I mean
I think you know because of Dodgers
mutation for example most polyploidy
okay I think that's an extant is the
product of escaping from deleterious
mutations okay so that's a that's a way
to temporarily get away from deleterious
mutation build-up now over deep time
this is where you you look at the total
number of polyploid that have been
successful in evolutionary time in
plants you know in deep evolution adds
50 different events but at any one time
there's tens of thousands of poly
players that are evolving it allows you
to short-term escape from deleterious
mutations for a few thousand years but
[Laughter]
are you against it yeah okay we can
swing talk later okay
thank you this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at cornell
edu